tout le comité de jumelage de guyancourt
s'est retroussé les manches
chacun a fabriqué des petits objets pour
les revendre ce jour là sur ce marché
solidaire bijoux vêtements produits
culinaires il y en avait pour tous les
goûts
alors j'ai acheté une petite poule pour
mettre dans mon jardin pour ma vraie
poule
ce que j'aimerais poule ça c'est de la
confiture parce que je suis gros les
recettes des ventes permettront aux
comités de financer des projets pour le
développement de com et au bénin ville
jumelle de guyancourt comme elle se
situe à 60 km de cotonou la capitale le
micro projet pour lequel nous
travaillons actuellement
c'est un projet de plantation de 300
arbres dans certaines rues de com et les
arbres seront plantés en juin prochain
par des enfants de comé afin de les
sensibiliser aux questions
environnementales
en 2008 le jumelage avait permis de
fournir une nouvelle pirogue pour que
les jeunes de com et puissent se rendre
à l'école au-delà de ces aides
le comité poursuit une autre ambition
découvrir connaître à avoir des échanges
avec les habitants d'autres pays donc
quand c'est en europe c'est assez près
de nous mais on a quand même des
cultures un peu différente avec un pays
qui se trouvent en afrique on a comment
dire d'autant plus d'inconnues séparer
de six mille six cents kilomètres les
deux villes profitent de ce type
d'événement pour créer un pont entre
deux cultures